to show us how to live and he lived
perfect without no blemish no sin he was
the only perfect he he lived perfect
okay he racism thing huh racism he
opposite so how is he racist okay I'll
tell you how when a woman she was a
canite yeah she came to see Jesus he a
dog that's not that's not a
color is not color it is about yes it is
yes it is yes it is R you finish it is
about race okay
race
we if I'm an alerian I look down you
because you're why did you look down on
her she was because she was from that
country not because of the country she
was a sinner dirty Sinner and he's
allowed to judge let me know she was a
canite not because she was sinner
because Israelite and sinners too but
even looked down to them so he compared
to because she was a canite and she was
asking and begging for hope for Jesus
didn't he help her he
help okay imagine you ask me for Hope i
s on you then I help you is it something
good well listen let me say it let me
say it in this way let me okay but then
cool was Muhammad
perfect he
I us example how
to Nature Nature he fall into
shortcoming fair enough but then cool
having a wife that's nine is is that all
right that time yes even this
time I'll tell you I'll tell you but
having sex with them is a
problem that they
had okay
ACC no problem according to the Old
Testament you allow to get married to
the woman when she is the age commit
what is the age listen nine is not the
age of I'm asking about n I'm asking wa
I don't you know more this about me okay
biologically the girl can age of puberty
which is
how you differentiate between adult and
a child is by the puberty okay and you
can check online don't take my word
check online at the age of eight eight
okay differ would you go out of 8y old
would you and you said that perfect you
with me I would do everything that Jesus
are you married huh you married I'm not
married I'm not I'm not would you get
married yeah eventually but never got
married so so you get married I'm God
not God Jesus is son of God Jesus is the
image of God he is the god is invisible
Jesus came to show
people Jus to show people how to live
because before they
would I can say what I want I like it I
like
it
back I believe in Islam as well in way
because you're submission to God but if
you don't believe in Christ then I don't
think you can make heaven and that's all
believe in everything I believe in the
Bible we believe in the Christ According
To Jesus according to Paul you believe
in Jesus according to Paul to Jesus
Christianity but I'm Kingdom of Heaven
I'm a bit I'm a step ahead of that I'll
let you finish and let you follow Jes
example huh yeah so so Jesus came to
show us how to live the perfect life
yeah Jesus never got married why you
getting married because listen the
reason why he got married he never got
married the church was his wife and
that's in the Bible CH the church was
his wife and look in the Bible there was
no church at time there was church but
Church listen look at the Bible Temple
no problem Jesus said love your wives as
I love the church so there was churches
then you just didn't know you just
ignorant in the fact that you didn't
know no it was church it says in the
Bible love your wife how I love the
church so he made the church while he
was alive no problem so Mar to a woman
he didn't need to be married to a woman
because he came to do one mission to
listen to Father up let me finish let me
finish let me finish and then you can he
came for one principle to save people
from dying in sin and going to hell in
judgment brother I'm saying this to you
not to argue with you I
love listen listen listen let me just I
understand you want to do the but let me
just talk Jesus came because the holy
God the invisible God cannot take one
bit of sin Christianity is not like
Islam where you can do good works and
way way no we do not we were dead in our
sins so that's like we being dead and
Jesus Is grabing Us with a lifu and
listen I'm the holiest I'm holy and if
you eat my bread and drink my blood you
will be saved and if you don't you will
you will try and be good and every
goodness to God is like filthy rags I
mean when you try and be good to God
he's perfect so we need Jesus or we will
die and go to hell can so we need Jesus
we need him that's only way Moes time
the people that follow Moses Jesus
alive me so the people that lived at the
time of Moses when God said to them okay
in the Torah if you do evil deed and you
be repent and you do righteous Deeds you
have eternal life eternal life so God
was here lying by saying if you do
righteous Deeds you have eternal life
without believe without believing Jesus
died for your sins that is in the Old
Testament okay let me
old we are not in need of
Jesus are not in need of Jesus all the
time you think talking to mes we are not
in need of Jesus we have finish we have
to finish Jesus in the in in invisible
you know you changing the argument the
argument is no change an argument no the
argument to remind you we have in need
of Jesus to be saved correct yes and God
does not uh what they call it New
Testament Jesus was the Redemption
because no because I can't because when
you're saying something is irrit in my
ear because because I'm going to I was
patient no but you wasn't you were
butting in you were patient for one time
one time
one you
be you said to remind of your argument
God doesn't accept your statement your
speech God doesn't accept even one sin
okay so Jesus I didn't say that I said
Jesus came I said that we
no no no we are s look listen we are
Sinners by Nature he sinner Jesus is not
a sinner no because he is Incarnate s
okay okay let me let me speak did he not
take our sins huh did he not take our
sin so you become sinner no lik of
sins likess likess says likess it didn't
say sin it likess of sin listen to Paul
what said Paul what
said Paul said Paul said Jesus became
cursed so Jesus and Satan according to
believe are the same Jesus is cursed and
Satan is cursed is that what you believe
though the Bible is that what you
believe in the Bible is that what you
believe Jesus cursed no I don't believe
Jesus when he say Jesus cursed well let
me speak let me let you speak let me let
you my question did Jesus lie did poor
lie when he said Jesus became cursed
listen you're your cherry pick in the
Bible answer my question I can't answer
something that's Cherry P how can you
question lie poor lie when he said Jesus
became cursed listen Jesus I ask you
that this poor lie when he the sin of
death sin means
death let me let me let me this no
church discussion after you go used to
church to be Jesus Cur for your s Paul
said that not me but Paul did he say it
like that say it how it says in
scripture don't be saying it problem
show it no show me your Bible get my
Bible and show me get your B and show me
where
because Jes became cursed because of our
sins and you're saying the Jesus is sin
Jesus likeliness and sin is different
doesn't say that Jesus became cursed
because of our show me and then I'll
explain it how if you don't know how you
going explain this because I will know
the Holy Ghost the Holy Spirit Holy
Spirit and I know my word you have Holy
Spirit I have the Holy Spirit sure yes I
do okay you I mean I might not be
showing the fruits of it right now cuz
it looks like I'm AR I have the Holy
Spirit if you have Holy Spirit tell me
what he says isaah 42 no I said holy
spirit I didn't say I know the word the
Bible inside Holy Spirit knows
everything the Holy Spirit knows
everything am I the Holy Spirit or is it
a holy spirit res help you is it going
to help you it will help me when I see
the Bible the Bible flies out of me if
Holy Spirit knows everything and it's
going to help show me where Paul said
I'm going to show you I'm going to show
you you said you said the Holy Spirit
you said the holy spirit will help you
the Holy Spirit knows everything correct
so tell the Holy Spirit to tell you what
is in Isaiah 42 do you want me to you
know what the holy spirit is telling me
right now is he telling you it's give
your to be Jesus and you will be saved
brother the story is brother and if you
don't you will burn in
eternity mhammad is not going to you I'm
being respectful I love mamed as well he
is not going to save you
Jesus Jesus is the Flesh of invisible
God if you cannot
speak come speaking to demon Jesus came
so then he can then preach to the people
and show them how to live how God would
want them to live do you know what I
mean and that's fly done by being racist
but he's not racist he told the canite
woman he said that she's a dog but
that's not racist would you like to call
you dog I wouldn't like it but it's true
I'm a 30 sinner so yes am a dog I used
to love yeah I was I was a dog until I
became a Christian I used to love having
sex but if Jesus call me a dog he's a
holy all the time but you how would you
know you a dog how would you know
exactly we would know but listen what
I'm saying what I'm saying if Jesus call
me a dog he is Holy and he is the Son of
God so you can call what because of your
race he not because oface
because no it's not because of that it's
because she was a sin was a dirty
doesn't say that doesn't have to he have
to read behind the line the doesn't say
making up he called her a dog because
she was from a different tribe racism
she was a Canon she was begging for her
so Jesus who L everyone woman
dog and he's allow to say that he
created dogs he was he S no he saw the
father create the doctor you talking
about and the doctor are more friendly
than humans so I would rather be a
doctor
humans are the one that's killing
everyone dogs are more peaceful and
friendly why you trying to what it I'll
tell you that you can go
to and
then Christ redeemed us from the curse
of the law by becoming Redeem Me by
becoming cursed so Jesus become cursed
and Carry On and carry on and what does
it say after that carry on reading
cursed For Us carry on reading it okay
for it is written curse everyone who is
hang on a PO carry on carry on that's
why
finish I mean you make it s not me
that's your book so cool so in the Bible
before you go off topic that don't do
red Jesus so much he basically committed
suicide to life that's what he saying he
became cursed C he became cursed so
Satan no he's not like Satan he became
cursed to save you so am I like Satan if
I gave myself cancer stop your cancer so
am I like Satan because I got
cancer becom cursed it good or bad
become cursed listen God become cursed
you can't become cursed because he I ask
you that becoming cursed is something
good or bad to become cursed it depends
who you are us as humans is bad tell me
what is curs mean I don't know I don't
care about being cursed I don't I don't
do my research you know what I to you
brother yeah stop blind following I'm
not because do you know why I'm not cuz
I got the Quran when I read the Quran
all I saw Satan is cursed huh Satan is
cursed so you know Jesus is not cursed
and you're talking that Jesus in your
Quran it says that Jesus is coming to
judge the world and where did I say go
on and get
the US do have aan do I have a quan go
you I help you say she's going to
judge you do it no you made the claim
not me you do it no you made proof upon
made the CLA I it up with the proof you
make come to judge you show me in the
Quran where it says J is going to come
back to judge the going to come to judge
in the Quran then if it says that then
what in the Quran yeah yes
Quran Jesus
I
mean it even says it
before read out read it out loud that's
out loud that's Quran let me get the get
the Quran
outan the
Quan every schol of the Quran pres what
you talking about the Quran what is it
the what is it then if it's not thean
where is it that's notan that's just
someone statement wait let me read it
every scholar of the Quran receed that
the hour is reference to the hour of
judgment okay Jesus also recognized what
that's not the Quran it's not the Quran
get the Quran now because they're going
to say that if it's just random news I'm
up li you look get your Quran cuz you
look one Quran you got all the your
Quran brother and I believe I mean
Muslims will go to heav 100% to they
just have to accept Jesus it doesn't
about being a Christian
Jesus
wasn't no me I don't care I'm emal but
care no it's it's just passion passion I
don't care so why is it be passion
emotional because passion passion
emtional because when we stop talking
this I'm your brother I talk about
having Ace day I'm up the I'm not a
chistian I'm AAL being the point here is
let me listen that you believe in Christ
in Christ becoming cursed and Satan
become cursed so Satan and Jesus are sa
Accord to you no not that's not
according to my belief let me just
become cursed you believe I believe
Jesus Is it true not he became cursed
for what to save so that doesn't make
what what you're saying Mak sense but
Jesus Is God correct yeah but then that
means the curse doesn't do nothing for
him because he's God and he's still
alive so he can take the curse because
if he didn't take the curse we would all
be dead that's contradiction though it's
not contradiction nothing is
contradiction to God it's contradiction
to you because you got you got you're
not God you don't know but the devil's
cursing he's alive yeah yeah but
The Devil Is Alive only because he was
in heaven and he was a fallen angel
that's why he alive because Spirits
cannot die so that's why the devil is
under the ground Spirit Well you I'm not
no mad Christian you're not mad
Christian I'm not no mad Christian but
you're asking me what Spirit you tell me
spirit is what's in as our body that's
what's making up is I'm going to let you
speak the this just dirt and the housing
the spirit is what's making me move
right now that is what a spirit is I
don't know how to the scientif no I'm
not saying you in the spirit I'm saying
you refer to something as a spirit who
is the spirit Satan in the spirit Satan
is the spirit Darkness ask a spirit and
Spirits can't so you finished now can I
speak now okay my point here is which
you have for if anyone want you have not
or you try to not pretend you not have a
Gras W Roma fragrances W full store Roma
I don't ramp okay you have not grasp
that in the Bible God was holy all the
time
one no this is
have a nice time with me with me I'm
linking my my sister right now pray to
the god of Jesus let's pray to the god
of Jesus the God so so so Jesus has a
god there yeah he's the son of he was
God yeah but listen you got you got you
got a cousin you got a cousin you got a
you're you're and me to my mom and her
son ah Subhan Allah
he left him as
that Subhan
Allah yeah that was an energetic one I
ain't going to lie that was really
energetic